لا قوه تعلو على قوه راس الدوله او حتى
توازيها مكانه ولا نصد دستوريا يردعه عن
فعل ما يحلو في عينه للقمع معارضيه وتوسيع
نفوثه وسيطرته على السلطات الاخرى
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضائيه التي
تعارفت المجتمعات الحديثه على اعتبار
الفصل في ما بينها اهم اسس لعبه
الديمقراطيه
ذاك ايجاز طالما صحفي وسط استبداد كثير من
الزعماء العرب على مدار عقود سبقه انفجار
ربيع العربي بدءا من تونس قبل 12
سنه في تونس نفسها عاقبا انتصار ثوره
الياسمين بان الحلقه تغيرت لان اعلان
الرئيس التونسي الاسبق زين العابدين بن
علي تفهمه لغضب شعبه بعد فوات الاوان قد
بدا منذ اذن درسا للمستبدين عموما ولما
سيخلفه في حكم بلاده على نحو الخاص كلامكم
اليوم
ونكلمكم الكل
في تونس وخرج تونس ستجري مياه كثيره تحت
الجسر وسيتعاقب على حكم تونس ثلاثه رؤساء
اخرين قبل ان تؤول مقاليد السلطه الى
الرئيس الحالي قيس سعيد الذي يتهمه
معارضوه بالانقلاب على الديمقراطيه والسعي
الى احياء الاستبداد في مقابل قوله
المتكرر انه يحاول انقاذ البلاد من الشلل
السياسي وواعيده المستمر بالانتصار على من
يصفهم بالخونه والعملاء
من القرارات المعركه التي شهدت على مدى 18
شهرا اتخاذ قرارات رئاسيه لتعزيز هيمنه
سعيد على السلطات التنفيذيه وتشريعيه
والقضائيه ما زالت تتوالى فصول وجديدها
مثل المحامي العياش الهمامي منسق هيئه
الدفاع عن القضاه المعزولين امام قاضي
التحقيق بتهمه
ونشر شائعه كاذبه اي حالتي على تحقيق
اليوم تندارج في تار سياسه قيس سعيد
وحكومته في التعاطي مع المختلفين عنهم في
الراي وهي سياسه العصايه الغريبه والاحاله
على القضاء وبث الرعب والتخويف وكان
الهمام الذي شغل من قبل منصب وزير حقوق
الانسان قد اتهم وزيره العدل بالامتناع عن
تنفيذ احكام قضائيه تنص على اعاده قضاه
معزولين الى وظائفهم مش افضله تنفيذ
الاحكام فقط هي بعد ما جابوا لها الاحكام
خبر تقتلهم ملفات وجات لهم
في الازمه التونسيه
لكنها اهميته تكمن ربما في انه يعكس
الخلافه بين رؤيتين تقوم احداهما وهي
المعارضه على اعتبار القضاء سلطه مستقله
بينما تقوم الثانيه التي يتبناها الرئيس
سعيد على اعتباره مجرد وظيف
وثم في السياق مسلسل خطوات رئاسيه وجهت
بمعرضه قطاعات واسعه من الطيف السياسي
والاجتماعي ابرزها حل مجلس النواب وحل
المجلس الاعلى للقضاء وصياغه واقرار دستور
جديد للبلاد من دون التشاور مع القوى
الفاعله ثم اجراء انتخابات تشريعيه لم
يشارك فيها سوى من نسبته 11 وربع في المئه
من الناخبين
المشهد التونسي اذن يزداد تعقيدا وفي
التعليق عليه يلاحظ مراقبون من ابناء
البلاد كيف يستعيدوا كثير معارضي الرئيس
الاسبق زين العابدين بن علي سيرتهم الاولى
عبره تحركات الاحتجاجيه ضد سياسات الرئيس
الحاليه قيس سعيد وطبعا وصفه عقيدا اضافيه
تشكله الازمه الاقتصاديه المستعصيه واخر
مظاهرها جحا في المواد التموينيه الاساسيه
وعلاجته احدى وسائل الاعلام الرسميه بدعوه
الناس الى الامتناع عن تناول الحليب لانه
مضر بصحه الكبار